choose your companions wisely and if
your friends are not raising the
vibration of what you're trying to
achieve or they're just giving you
and making fun of you and whenever
you're Earnest and share a goal or a
dream they put you down it might be time
to upgrade and that's harsh and there's
gracious ways of doing that but I think
it's important to seek out people who
support you and find older people who
are a little bit further down the path
who can say here's how did it or I see
where you're struggling plenty of those
people are around and it doesn't have to
be one person I think everybody should
have a board of advisers or a council of
directors and I can tell you as somebody
who's been practicing that for a very
long time it's improved my life in ways
I couldn't possibly tabulate like it is
incredibly important who you spend your
time with